it's taken these investigators a year to
determine exactly what happened in the
final moments of Lion Air flight 610
their final crash report blames a
combination of factors including design
flaws in Boeing 737 max jet as well as
maintenance problems and inadequate
pilot training the Lyon airplane crashed
into the Java Sea 12 minutes after
takeoff from Indonesia's capital Jakarta
all 189 people on board died including
Anton's ahadees cousins
he says he's disappointed with the
report's conclusions we actually had big
hopes that the government would answer
all our questions but the information
we've been given adds almost nothing to
what we already know the report
highlights problems with Boeing's
anti-stall software known as MCAS it's
also implicated in a similar crash in
Ethiopia in March which led to the
grounding of the Mac's fleet worldwide
it's significant because it sort of
reaffirms that Boeing does share
responsibility for this for the way they
design the in caste system which is the
maneuvering characteristics saying that
basically took control away from the
pilots and the pilots we're having to
fight the airplane pilots flying the
lion air jet had reported problems the
day before it crashed analysts say it
should have been grounded for further
tests I feel that safety is not yet the
core concern in Indonesia except for the
flag carrier Airlines I'm worried about
the private aviation companies because
even though on paper they're checked by
safety inspectors accidents keep
happening Boeing has already paid a high
price for two 737 max crashes within
five months its chief executive was
fired and the company's income has
halved engineers have been forced to
redesign software and Boeing needs to
convince aviation regulators the
grounded Jets are safe to take off again
Victoria Gaytan B al Jazeera